hey Vsauce Michael here this point of
light in the sky is earth as seen from
the surface of Mars and this is Earth as
seen from Saturn here's an image taken
only 45 thousand kilometers away the
famous Blue Marble but what does Earth
really look like well it depends on how
you define look the word look comes from
the old breton word Lagoon meaning I the
human eye and that's part of the problem
images like this are based on light
humans can see but we don't see
everything there's a fantastic episode
of radio lab that uses sound to
illustrate just how different other
creatures visual spaces are from our own
when we talk about the way something
physically looks we are talking about
the visual perception of emitted or
reflected electromagnetic radiation
specifically visible light light we
perceive as red has a longer wavelength
than blue or violet but what if I crank
the wavelength even shorter does it stop
being light no it just becomes light you
can't see ultraviolet x-rays gamma rays
going the other way
you get infrared microwaves and finally
radio waves in principle the spectrum of
possible electromagnetic wavelengths is
infinite but even within the range of
wavelengths we observe the breath is
breathtaking if the entire practical
spectrum of wavelengths was laid out
linearly from New York to Los Angeles
the visual portion we see would only be
the size of 100 nanometers small enough
to slip through a surgical mask point is
when it comes to what there is to see
our eyes miss out on a lot for instance
take a look at a remote control many of
these things communicate with light of
wavelengths we can't see but mobile
phone cameras can try this at home
push a button on a remote control and
you won't see much but use a mobile
phone camera to detect wavelength so you
can't see and have the rendered visible
there's a whole lot going on we miss out
on our night sky is full of frequencies
we can't see with our eyes alone but
chroma scope net allows you to extend
your vision this is the Milky Way as we
see it the visible light it gives off
but slide to see how it would look at
our eyes sensed other frequencies of
course we are having to represent these
other frequencies with visible colors
because even electromagnetic pretend
time is bounded by our puny limits as
for Earth if we only saw infrared
frequencies it might look something like
this in our minds ultraviolet and
extreme ultraviolet vision would return
unrecognizable spheres with x-ray vision
Aurora's around the poles would shine
brightly and gamma-ray vision would give
earth a bright edge from high-energy
electromagnetic radiation hitting the
atmosphere at a shallow angle so which
view is correct
is there an absolute true appearance of
the earth we haven't even started yet
look back at the blue marble
what's with the tyranny of north meaning
up perhaps it's because we often equate
up with better and many early map makers
were from north of the Equator
but upside-down maps are equally true no
matter how strange they may seem to us
funny enough the famous Blue Marble
itself is a product of North equals up
bias it didn't originally look like this
the crew of Apollo 17 originally took it
like this
NASA rotated it to fit our traditional
ID
up after the fact here's a visual of
earth that comes from the US Naval
Observatory x' live animation of our
planet you can see exactly what parts
are in its shadow at this very moment
other shadows fall on earth as well like
the moon's shadow last week bad
astronomers shared this image the dark
smudge on the left is actually the
moon's shadow during a solar eclipse as
seen from above Earth there's another
problem with the Blue Marble it's flat
and the earth is three-dimensional a
globe is the best way to represent the
earth but globes are difficult to carry
around and even when displayed in two
dimensions well you just can't see
everything at once a flat map of the
earth is really convenient but it
requires projecting a globe onto
something flat and a spheres surface
cannot be represented on a plane without
distortion the west wing famously
pointed out the limitations of Flat Maps
there is no such thing as a perfect flat
map of the entire world some maps are
useful for some things and other maps
for other things but it is really fun to
pick on the Mercator projection mainly
because it's so popular and is even used
by Google Maps mainly because it's so
easy to zoom in on it preserves shape
decently well but suffers when it comes
to area as I've shown before Africa is
huge its area is so large the entire
contiguous United States could fit
inside of it along with all of China
India Japan and much of Europe but on
the Mercator projection scale near the
poles is pretty wonky distorted which
means Greenland appears to be as large
as Africa even though in reality it is
only one 14th the size that is more
check out Alaska and Brazil on a
Mercator projection they appear almost
the same size but in reality Brazil is
nearly 5
times bigger than Alaska areas near the
equator are minimized whereas areas
closer to the poles are exaggerated to
have fun with this problem play the
Google Maps Mercator puzzle the red
pieces are countries projected outside
of their usual locations now what the
heck is this weird shape well let's pull
it away from the North Pole where scale
is distorted a lot and now it's
Australia you can see how the math
behind map projections to store Earth by
interacting with them on Jason Davies
brilliant site notice how small
Greenland appears on the Mercator
projection when pulled down to be
equator and how exaggerated it becomes
when moved to the edge to be fair the
Mercator projection is great for
navigation if you want something that is
more fair when it comes to area try the
gall Peters here land masses are the
right relative size but shape is
sacrificed everything looks a bit too
narrow enter the mole by D this
projection shows equal areas and is a
bit more pleasant shape wise if you
interrupt the mo by D around the oceans
relative area is preserved and the shape
of land masses becomes even more
accurate when it comes to the shortest
route between two places on the surface
of the earth mnemonic projections are
really cool every straight-line journey
taken on Earth's surface is actually
part of a great circle on Mercator
projections actual straight-line paths
look curved but every straight line on a
gnomonic projection is also a straight
line in real life the shortest route if
you want a compromise between shape and
area you might try the pleasant winkel
Tripel which the National Geographic
Society has used for maps it produces
since 1998 or a beautiful butterfly map
that could be a ball until it's
flattened save under a pane of glass the
Dymaxion map
can unfold to show how nearly connected
Earth's landmasses
are it's a great way to visualize human
migration over time it's quite
impressive how far and wide humans have
traveled on earth but it remains a bit
of a disappointment to realize just how
narrow our slice of visual perception
really is but don't feel bad this brings
us to the story of Julianne Bayliss yes
hello is this dr. Julianne Bayliss yes
Bayliss told me about how one day while
using Google Earth he spotted some dark
green vegetation it looked like a rain
forest an expedition was scheduled and
it turned out to be just that a rain
forest we had previously never seen I
asked him more so what have you found
there thank you found about twelve new
species there just four Maru so we found
about three snakes two chameleons are
bad about four per the Flies two new
species of farms and we've only really
just been into the forest edge so I read
it I read a paper the other day a
scientific paper they estimate that
there's maybe eight million eight and a
half million species in this world but
we've only actually discovered one and a
half million or opportunity one and a
half and two million so we've actually
only discovered maybe one-fifth of
everything that's living on this planet
Wow our eyes only see a tiny fraction of
what there is to see but within that
tiny fraction there are still an
enormous number of things left to find
so keep searching keep looking and as
always thanks for watching
[Music]